welcome to this video playing mellow 333
from Austria I hope let's see oh it says
he likes my channel thanks so we get the
news oh this is also why he took a few
seconds to play this only moves okay the
NIMS oh and i'm going to try to go for
the hoop no variation let's see what is
playing no yeah here i have picked up
this interesting line with c6 it it
makes a slightly weird impression but
it's not really bad getting later D 5n
and the bishop is quite well positioned
on c7 while White has made many moves cm
that that way it's not so clear what
they actually doing maybe five
immediately yeah why they expand but
they also weaken get you five and now i
can take here that's interesting
intermediate move to get get widen
isolated Queens pawn check i have this
immediate this intermediate check okay
95 mm I always yeah maybe 95 maybe
White's needs to take out now I can
capture with the Queen yeah this looks
quite nice the only thing is my queen
site is totally undeveloped so maybe I
wonder if I should maybe consider and I
know it looks totally strange come on
i'm still doing it still doing it I
don't feels weird I'm still doing it
come on I want I want a quick
development if
the ideas HD and here Bishop if I've
quickly get the pieces out and now if he
wants to avoid the trade which would
really help me I have to to set up the
light square blockade if he wants to
avoid the church needs to play Bishop e2
and this is not really an active move so
I can play 97 answering Bishop f3 with
Bishop g4 and having Knight b6 possibly
95 later yep Knight b6 queen d 6 and
then 25 something like that I have this
one and now it's hard for him to avoid
the trade as g2x
that's very nice position
yeah should I take or not it's not not
necessary at the moment maybe maybe do
this first Knight b6 was also an idea
giving me the additional possibility to
to go to see form okay let's let's get
rid of this and now maybe just queen d 7
at night to d5 p.m. on or not rook c5 is
not really in great a great threat maybe
I can first strengthen the e-file here
rook e8 first c5 final oh I just go to
d7 and it's not so clear what the rook
is doing
Yahoo p895 convince is just a very bad
bishop the same same color then the then
the IGP okay five was probably a good
move right yeah looks looks like a good
defense it's a maybe no oh briefly
thought that d5 would be possible but
it's probably not really good because a
seven-run trading d44 a seven would be
of course very beneficial but I can I
can take on e6 that can even take with
the Queen IAM prevent any all that yeah
my next move was probably just 95 and
then yep night or take here take it's
not helping just just do this now e5 is
threatened I guess but there's also just
yeah those traits um I can take with the
Queen actually and set up this really
uncomfortable pin maybe even threatening
f5f for him I have the checkered so
which is not doing much admittedly okay
but she has no discovery I mean yeah 2g5
or something but the trade is just okay
for me yeah just play the end game or
yeah come on yes just play this check
this great endgame been to c4
yeah and it's just I cannot I must I
don't need to do it directly let's start
with this get the King involved okay
King c4 is probably probably some sort
of a threat I don't yeah I don't want
the King to to go down and in general I
want king is six night be 694 25 okay
yeah well if it takes I have a passer on
the edge farm so nothing I particularly
dislike okay no over to see form what
start with Nazi for maybe start with
this
I can now take and play h5 for the
passer mmm if you can play f3 though
maybe just go here and threaten this and
then aged five still f3 okay so just
start with h 5 I don't need to take
first the upcoming passed pawn on the H
file is some is a problem he needs to
build the bishop to defensed against
defend against it and the bishop also
has the a three-pointer to take care of
you know I can take the fall and I will
take take the material what's quickest
time morning I just get the opponent's
probably the easiest ice cut this this
slight counter play him hmm
this I should have dessert that could
have played more precisely i guess
counter-attacking on f3m so that I keep
I keep things under control check check
white forfeits on time yeah at the end I
can just go over here and win the beef
or pawn yeah it was just a very
uncomfortable position I mean around
here after after this I think black is
so quite in quite good shape get amazing
misjudgment by stockfish giving this
position as equal it's a quite quite
funny um yeah why should this position
be equal I have a complete blockade over
d 5 enter nothing nothing ever going to
happen here to black and you can just
play this on forever and ever and ever
against iqp okay this is not helping but
and some just a very one-sided position
yeah and here we I computer here gave me
something better yeah f5 okay I didn't
mind his endgame it is it is very very
much better for for black this g4 was
very helpful for me so I get the H porn
in addition but first I improved them
the situation as far as possible only
then
got the H pawn age born running here I
could have played better no doubt about
it I going over to be three and taking
on a three SS useless I should just keep
the king near there five and let them
let the night do the job on its own
that's easiest like like this for
example the king is going to protect
this pawn and this is just promoting
okay thanks for watching